well um the key takeaways are that the
united states and the united kingdom
share so much in common we share values
we share history
we share
a similar outlook
in terms of
the challenges that we face in today's
global economy um and i think we share
a lot of interests and opportunities so
i'm delighted to have been here visiting
scotland and london on the second part
of the
dialogues on the future of atlantic
trade and
where this takes us
i'm really open-minded about where this
takes us i'm extremely optimistic about
opportunities that we have to
collaborate
to expand upon everything that we share
in order to deliver uh meaningful
concrete
results for our workers um our
businesses our communities and our
economies
i mean such positive uh rhetoric there
and clearly lots of meetings that that
keep taking place i'm sure you'll be
aware that for some people in the uk
that that holy grail of a full free
trade deal with the us
appears to be quite elusive and
relatively delayed you know years after
the brexit has taken place is that your
perspective as well would you like to
get to that full free trade deal fairly
soon well let me say a little bit about
my perspective which is what we do in
trade and economics
has to make sense for our economies and
our people
with respect to the partners that we
work with but also with respect to the
challenges that we're facing the global
economy that we are living in today is
significantly different from the one
just
two and a half years ago in that time
we've had significant
public health crisis followed by an
economic crisis and supply chain
disruptions caused by the covid pandemic
and just in the last two months we've
had russia's invasion of ukraine which
in addition to being a foreign policy
crisis national security crisis is also
going to have economic impacts that we
are all going to have to deal with and
how important are those extra aspects of
factors that you have in common when you
when you come to prioritize who you're
negotiating with does president biden
tell you to focus purely on the
economies that would give the most
benefits to in terms of a trade deal or
economy like the uk because of security
discussions happening in and around the
war does that push us higher up the list
i think we take each partner on its own
[Music]
i don't think that we have a list
i certainly don't keep one
but in terms of our trade relations
we have been working very hard to build
on a rebuild aspects of the u.s uk
partnership and alliance
we spent a good part of the last year
working out
and investing in this relationship we
resolved a 17-year long wto dispute
between airbus and boeing
in the last couple months we have
resolved the tensions around steel and
aluminum trade in both cases we are
setting ourselves up for
constructive
and new approaches to collaborating in
trade and economics and i think that
with respect to this bilateral
relationship there are a lot of
challenges that we face together
including
challenges from non-market economic
systems
that
um affect our competitiveness in the
global environment i wanted to touch on
the the trade sanctions placed on on
russia given the war and clearly there's
all sorts of sanctions and and the trade
sanctions are just one area of them what
is the perspective from the u.s
administration on what it would take to
then see those sanctions
lifted is it a case of a simple end to
the war and all the sanctions are lifted
or is it very hard for president putin's
regime to earn back the trust and favor
of the u.s administration i think that
again in this situation
the
the dynamics are
are changing and constantly changing we
don't know how this is going to go
nothing is predestined and that means
that for all of us
the us the uk
the european union
all standing together in alliance
against
president putin and his aggression
against ukraine
we have have all and we are all making
choices and we're doing it together and
that is a really critical critical
aspect of this um i don't quite know how
this will resolve but i think that the
emphasis that i will put here
is on the partnership that we see
between the u.s the uk the europeans
other allies in taking joint action
and really standing up for a system of
values and principles that is important
to our vision of a better world
and just bringing things back to the uk
u.s relationship
what are the key things that you'd like
to see from british business and the
british government that would speed up
the process of
some form of a free trade deal well uh
let me put it this way what i have seen
from
the british government and the british
people is also a shared set of
priorities and values around the need
for resilience for sustainability in
terms of our economic relations and
ensuring that our economic and trade
system
is incentivizing
behavior that puts the interests of our
people and our planet first because
without that
uh we're all in very deep trouble and
and a free trade deal is what a year
away or or many many years away again
we will see what form our collaboration
takes but regardless of the form
i think that there is a lot that we have
to accomplish together